[Music]
what are some of the trends for shopping
this holiday season given that we are
experiencing a period we've
never been in before kirsten joyce
joining us with the details kirsten
on an hours-long webinar today on data
collected by prosper data and analytics
this is basically what the national
retail federation uses
when it wants to read what people are
projected to do for a particular time
period
now the results show that 64 percent of
adults 18 years of age and older plan to
spend the same or less this year on
holiday spending
compared to last year and while we all
know online shopping is at an all-time
high during the pandemic it doesn't make
up for the fact that brick and mortar is
struggling
now the shop small movement appears to
be gaining strength as consumers want to
avoid the bigger crowds and get what
they need and get out
they also want that personal touch and
to support the smaller businesses
the trends also show that a certain type
of advertising seems to be working
and away email has become the dominant
player especially during the holiday
season
um you know we're all getting a number
of emails from retailers from brands
uh you know and and so those emails
appear to be the best return on
investment
for avatar from an advertising um
standpoint trends show that while there
are plenty of people who may feel
comfortable
shopping on their smartphones there's
still plenty of older consumers the gen
xers who are more comfortable doing it
from the desktop
and i'm definitely in one of those
categories denise the older generation